voici frais britney 102 où nous parlons
des questions liées au mouvement free
britney free plaide pour la fin de la
mise sous tutelle de britney spears pour
une femme lucide qui n'a pas arrêté de
travailler
ça n'a aucun sens c'est un break mais je
m'appelle elisabeth deenen et j'ai 29
ans je m'appelle james miller je suis de
bâton rouge en louisiane
je m'appelle jasmin j'ai 28 ans et je
suis un scorpion du new-jersey chère
britney chère britney heureusement je
suis nerveux il transpirait la situation
m'inquiète
j'arrive pas à croire que ça dure depuis
si longtemps et que j'en savais rien je
savais pas ce que je faisais mais on
apprend chaque jour on gagne en sagesse
pourquoi ça continue pourquoi son père
décide pour elle j'ai toujours été
convaincu que ça ne serait jamais arrivé
à un homme ici en amérique
croyez moi il ya des jours où je me bats
je fais confiance au système la loi est
faite pour protéger les personnes et
sous tutelle raconter des choses sur moi
qui ne sont pas tout à fait vrai hand
soutien britney et on tiendra jusqu'à ce
que tu sois livre